[Applaudissements]
nous allons vous proposer une expérience
politique l'expérience ma voix alors on
n'est pas un parti politique
en fait on n'a même pas de programme
politique bien sûr on encore un petit
programme c'est d'aller à la rencontre
de la démocratie non effectivement tu as
raison c'est une idée assez simple la
démocratie en fait ces deux mots demos
le peuple et kratos le pouvoir ça vous
le savez le pouvoir au peuple
alors pendant cette expérience on va
vous mettre un petit peu à contribution
si vous le voulez bien on va vous faire
entendre plusieurs mois l'une après
l'autre
si en entendant une de ces bois vous
dites ça peut être la mienne vous levez
la main
ok j'ai pas vraiment l'impression que
les politiques me ressemble super merci
pour la participation
je ne vois plus j'estime que je n'ai
plus à prendre part au système et à le
cautionner elle fait un peu moins
consensus à faire ça mais un caisson
celle là parce que je l'autre mijote le
par principe par obligation on est
d'accord
une dernière je ne fais plus confiance
aux politiques mais j'ai confiance en
nous les citoyens c'est vrai vous venez
d'entendre sous les notes ce sont celles
de nos amis nos familles mais aussi de
connaissance de rencontre moi j'ai voulu
partie parler des gens qui ne votent
plus ces gens qui ne votent plus non pas
par désintérêt la politique mais par
dégoût par rancoeur pour li respect
qu'on leur envoie ou trois mois ce sont
plutôt les voix des gens qui votent
encore mais plus par obligation morale
comme un devoir citoyen vote par
principe par habitude formé par
opposition à un candidat du coût de ces
phrases naisse un constat simple c'est
celui du bug démocratique et c'est de ça
qu'on est parti
donc ce tableau il vous évoque peut-être
quelque chose peut-être vos vieux
bouquins d'histoire ou quelques musées
que vous avez côté c'est la liberté
guidant le peuple
moi ça m'évoque la révolution la prise
de la bastille en 1789 en fait mai 1789
c'est aussi l'année où nous avons créé
l'assemblée nationale jeudi nous parce
que ce sont nos ancêtres notre héritage
notre patrimoine commun ça fait plus de
deux cents ans qu'est l'assemblée
nationale des hommes et des femmes
s'expriment en notre nom
alors en notre nom pas si sûr est ce que
vous connaissez le taux de participation
aux dernières élections législatives
j'imagine que non alors c'est 55,4 pour
155 4 % c'est le taux le plus bas jamais
atteint sous la vème république
cela veut dire que pendant cinq ans des
lois ont été votées au sein d'une
assemblée qui est plus de la moitié des
français
en fait on pourrait vous parler on
aurait pu vous parler de beaucoup
d'autres chiffres on aurait pu évoquer
le vote blanc l'abstention ou encore les
trois millions de français qui sont pas
inscrits sur les listes électorales
mais en fait on aurait abouti à la même
idée le système démocratique actuel il
échoue à nous représenter
pourquoi il échoue il échoue parce qu'il
réduit notre capacité d'action a glissé
un bulletin dans une urne tous les cinq
ans il y joue pas ce qu'il confie ce
même bulletin aux logiques de partie aux
intérêts personnels et au lobby il
échoue parce qu'ils n'évoluent pas dans
un monde qui lui est toujours plus
ouvert plus transparent plus
interconnecté donc de cette crise de la
représentation de ce bug démocratique
nous sommes partis et nous avons créé ma
mort et ma voix alors une fois qu'on a
dit ça
une fois qu'on a constaté ce bug
démocratique qu'est ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce que vous concrètement vous
faites au quotidien pour vous approprier
la démocratie
suggestion voilà ce qu'on vous propose
en juin 2017
vous allez pouvoir acquis et l'assemblée
nationale a hacké ce gros mot qu'est ce
qu'on veut dire par là on veut dire
qu'en face on voudrait utiliser les
failles de ce système pour s'y
introduire et le modifier donc le projet
de ma voix c'est qu'en juin 2017 nous
allons faire entrer à l'assemblée
nationale des citoyens formez volontaire
et tirés au sort et le principe c'est
que tous les cinq ans pendant cinq ans
excusez moi il relaie nos décisions que
nous nous avons exprimé sur une
plateforme internet sécurisé qui alors
imaginez un instant on est en septembre
2010 cet essai la rentrée parlementaire
il ya un texte de loi sur l'éducation
qui va être soumis à l'assemblée
nationale et vous qu'en tant que citoyen
vous sentez concerné vous avez envie d'y
prendre part alors pendant 15 jours vous
allez prendre connaissance du texte sur
la plateforme discuter des articles de
lois des amendements la loi et si vous
éprouvez des difficultés n'y aura pas de
souci parce qu'il y aura d'autres
personnes pour vous expliquer schéma
voir on fonctionne de pair à pair et à
l'issue de cette période de réflexion
commune vous prononcerez pour le texte
contre le texte où vous vous absentez ok
donc 50% d'entre vous votre pour 50%
d'entre vous votre contre immédiatement
quand il voit ses résultats
les députés m'avoua vote à 50% pour à
550 onces en contre en fait c'est très
simple si vous votez rouge
il vote rouge si vous votez bleus il
vote bleu si l'idée super simple à
démocratie bon peut-être que vous vous
dites dans un coin de votre tête
qu'est ce qui va obliger ses députés ma
voix à suivre nos consignes de vote
rien
en fait on s'est dit on actuellement on
fait déjà confiance aux partis
politiques pour porter notre voix
alors pourquoi ne pas faire confiance à
notre voisin pour la porter également on
a on n'a cessé de renoncer schéma voit
en fait on voudrait essayer c'est le
propre d'une expérience
mais les députés sont quand même un peu
obligé moralement ils ont une obligation
morale en fait qu'ils se divisent en
trois points se former c'est à dire
suivre une formation en ligne pour
comprendre le fonctionnement de
l'assemblée nationale parce qu'on pense
que pour hacker un système il faut en
comprendre les codes le langage
le deuxième engagement moral du député
ce sera de siéger 100% du temps
législatif c'est quand même la base et
ensuite ce sera de nous représenter
correctement
donc c'est à dire de voter en fonction
de nos propres opinions exprimées sur la
plateforme l'expérience ma voix c'est
aussi plusieurs principes et le premier
vous le voyez juste ici c'est la
dépersonnalisation
on pense que la politique c'est pas un
nom un visage
la politique ça doit juste être le
reflet de ce que vous pensez le second
principe c'est la coopération parce que
la multitude appellent à coopérer
nous utiliserons les outils horizontaux
et coopératif et enfin on défend un
principe d'indépendance financière grâce
à un financement participatif par et
pour les citoyens
on aura donc la dépersonnalisation la
coopération horizontale et
l'indépendance financière
on tient vraiment à ses principes parce
qu'on est convaincu que grâce à eux on
parviendra à éviter les écueils de la
politique actuelle néanmoins on est
quand même conscient des défis à
surmonter rose propose pas une idée
comme ça on est conscient que tout ne va
pas se faire d'un coup de baguette
magique
pourquoi parce que le bloc démocratique
aussi c'est qu'on se sent incapable en
fait de prendre part au débat
on pense que notre voix ne compte pas
que nos pouvoirs d'action est totalement
un film ça c'est faux donc on voudrait
relever deux défis chez ma voix
le premier défi c'est d'abord de
réapprendre à émettre un avis de
défendre un texte d'émettre une opinion
le confronter aux autres et ensuite de
l'assumer par le vote ça c'est le
premier livre
ensuite il va falloir évidemment pas
savoir comment fonctionne cette plate
forme donc
appropriée des outils numériques
collaboratif que nous utiliserons pour
exprimer nos opinions et c'est une fois
qu'on va relever ces deux défis qu'on
pourra ensuite s'attaquer au défi un peu
ultime qui sera de travailler sur les
textes de loi voire même à terme de
proposer nos textes de loi c'est ça en
fait le but final de cette expérience
ma voix n'est pas une utopie en fait
c'est même une expérience qui a déjà été
tentée à strasbourg en 2015 à strasbourg
lors d'élections où il s'attire anticipé
il ya 4 % des électeurs qui ont glissé
un bulletin de ma voix dans les jambes
alors 4 % ça n'a pas été suffisant pour
entrer à l'assemblée nationale mais
capon sens était déjà considérable pour
un mouvement qui avait à peine quelques
semaines on vous le répète ma voix n'est
pas une utopie
c'est une expérience politique qui se
déploie déjà aujourd'hui à travers 40
groupes locaux en france ce sont des
hommes et des femmes de tout horizon
social politique de tout âges de toutes
croyances qui chaque semaine à leur
échelle vont sur les marchés dans la rue
à la sortie des facs dans les bars il
parle à monsieur et madame tout le monde
il essaye de les convaincre une
démocratie directe est possible alors
vendredi
ma voix a franchi une étape très
importante on est à moins de 100 jours
des élections législatives et l'appel à
candidature a été lancé l'appel à
candidatures qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que chacun d'entre vous
vous pouvez écrire votre nom sur la
liste des potentiels futurs députés ma
voix et peut être à terme entre hélas
ici à l'assemblée nationale dans le
monde entier des mouvements ne naisse
répand dans tout ça la même soif de
démocratie un âne mexique argentine
venise italie espagne islande grèce
irlande canada et dans des villes et
villages français partout dans le monde
des initiatives portent la volonté des
peuples à prendre leur place à la table
des décisions et nous ici seul nous
prêts
ma voix pure je pense qu'on vous a dit
maintenant que vous soyez de simples
curieux
peut-être des futurs votants à ou même
peut-être des députés ma voix je vous
dis à vous de jouer et on se retrouve
[Applaudissements]